Disney's showed Jesse follows the Ross
family and the other people that are
part of their lives this show portrays a
variety of friendly and enemy
relationships and more importantly
romantic relationships throughout the
Jesse show seasons the audience is
exposed to crushes love triangles
budding relationships and heartbreaks
the romantic lives of characters on the
Jesse show are interesting but so are
the real actor and actresses love lives
to get the juicy details of
relationships on and off the screen of
the jesse show keep watching oh oh
what's the matter
the star of the jesse show Jessie
Prescott had numerous romances that is
one of Jessie's ex-boyfriends from her
previous life in Fort Hood the only guy
Jessie had ever dumped was Ted plus you
dumped me by texting my mom and she
described him as if he were a troll
which is ironic because he later became
an attractive male model Jessie you
didn't seem so interested when I look
like a before picture another one of
Jesse's ex-boyfriends is Brody Brody is
portrayed as a mega jerk and their
relationship is short-lived because of
this fact Jessie had some serious
relationships on the show one of which
was Tony Tony is the doorman of the Ross
family's building which is how they met
their romance begins in the first season
and they begin dating partway through
the season after a while they decide to
break up and remain friends friends
always but are still open about the fact
that they love each other later on in
the show they reignite the old flame and
get back together
Jesse's other serious lover is Brooks
who she meets and becomes engaged with
in season 3 Jesse breaks off the
engagements because she realizes she's
not ready to share a life with someone
after the engagements ending Jesse's
convinced that Brooks isn't over her so
the Ross family visits Africa to see him
when they arrive they see Brooks has a
new girlfriend kami she's my girlfriend
and he's completely over Jessie much to
her surprise mook was one of Jesse's
admirers throughout the show but jesse
has no interest in him wow that is
action-packed he tries hard to Wow
Jessie but is unsuccessful and
eventually realizes she's not interested
they remain good friends on the show
though the actress who plays Jessie
Debbie Ryan has an interesting life off
the screen - Debbie recently got married
to Josh Dunn who is the drummer of the
band
twenty one pilots the couple has had a
lot of happiness in their relationship
recently but it hasn't always been that
way they began dating way back in 2013
and dated on and off ever since at the
end of 2018
Josh popped the question and now the
couple is officially married hopefully
the couple doesn't have to endure any
more waves and it's smooth sailing from
here Jessie is Zuri Ross's nanny but
they're also best friends almost like a
mother and daughter jerry has bromances
of her own on the show one of which is
not Stewart Stewart has a hopeless crush
on Zuri but she doesn't feel the same
way about him in fact she gets rather
annoyed by Stewart's crush on her there
are signs that she likes him back which
is confirmed later on in the show
nothing ever becomes of their
relationship though they simply stay
friends
Zuri has some other love interests as
well including Tommy and Shane
Tommy is Zuri's ex-boyfriend as for
Shane Zuri has a massive crush on him
but nothing ever happens between them
because of how much time Zuri spends
with Stuart Shane rejects Missouri
because she feels Stuart is too much of
a competitor it turns out that Shane was
right because Dury eventually realizes
her feelings for Stuart Zuri is played
by Skye Jackson in real life Skye has
dated around a fair bit in 2019 she had
casual relationships with famous Jay and
Lil Keith before that she had dated Kidd
trunks Skye has only had brief casual
relationships in the past but this is
understandable since she's still very
young it'll be interesting to see how
Skye blossoms in her life and who she'll
date in the future on the Jessie shows
Irie has an older sister Emma Ross one
of Emma's ex-boyfriends is Caleb who is
also the stepbrother of Jessie another
ex-boyfriend of Emma is Vincent who is
your typical bad-boy type of course
things don't work out between them most
likely because of his rebellious nature
but you can't blame Emma for taking an
interest during the show emma has a
boyfriend by the name of Xander their
relationship isn't a major part of the
show though Emma's character is played
by Peyton lists Peyton is currently
single but she was in a serious
relationship with Cameron Monaghan from
the TV show shameless
the couple started dating in 2017 and
broke up in January of 2019 they never
come into publicly on why they broke up
but it appears they ended on good terms
the two still work together occasionally
and don't let the
past get in the way of their
professional lives Payton is quite young
and has lots of time to explore her
romantic future yet another member of
the Ross family is Ravi Ross one of
Robbie's love interests on the Jessie
show is Connie she's better known as
creepy Connie because she's crazy
obsessive and psychotic Connie has an
intense crush on Luke and Ravi has a
hopeless crush on Connie which creates
an engaging love triangle
throughout most of the show Connie is
desperately trying to get Luke to like
her she begins dating Ravi but the
relationship is super short probably
because she was never into Ravi in the
first place she even goes as far as to
deny they ever dated but Ravi gets her
to admit it since he has proof Ravi also
goes in a date with Jax a girl from his
chemistry class Ravi takes Jax to a
school dance but they don't date beyond
that Jax might be the one who got away
Ravi is played by Karan Brar Karan is in
a serious relationship with Sophie
Reynolds they have been dating since
2016 which is quite a long time Sophie
is also in showbiz and most often works
as an actress although she's trained
professionally as a dancer in various
genres the couple husband together for a
long time let's hope they continue
forward for more years to come Bertram
is the butler of the Ross family he is
often miserable about his job and
responsibilities on the show but deep
down he loves all four children of the
Ross family Bertram has one love
interest throughout the whole show Salma
Espinosa Salma is the cook for the Ross
family and lives in the same building
she also enjoys salsa dancing in her
spare time
who wouldn't be attracted to a salsa
dancer Bertram develops a crush on her
which Luke and Emma took notice of
because he becomes distracted by Salma
in one of the episodes the two rushed
children set them up together in the
lobby which appears to be successful in
real life Bertram is played by Kevin
Chamberlin at the moment Kevin isn't
dating anyone
even though Kevin is single now that
doesn't mean that he won't meet someone
special in the future hopefully he finds
his soul mate one day
another staff member of the Ross
family's building is Tony he's the
doorman as we saw before Tony had a
relationship with Jesse but it didn't
work out in his favor it's a shame
because the duo expressed their love for
one another but have a rocky
relationship together and choose to be
friends in the end another lover of Tony
is Victoria she is Tony's ex-girlfriend
and appears in the episode where Jesse
and Tony break up after their brief
relationship off screen Tony is really
Chris galya Chris began dating a
previously close friend
hadar Catania a number of years ago
Heather is a fashion brand consultant
and therefore a total fashion expert she
even has experience working with mega
fashion magazines the couple originally
met in 2012 and have remained a couple
ever since the couple has been together
for so long it looks like they're going
to be together forever the father of the
four children on the Jessie show is
Morgan Ross Morgan is a family man and
is married to Christina Ross the married
couple are often working and don't make
meeting appearances on the show unless
it's a special occasion like Christmas
later on in the show Christina quits her
job and becomes a stay-at-home mom which
eliminates the need for a full-time
nanny Jessie loses her job but not all
is lost because she can pursue her dream
career in Hollywood
Morgan is portrayed by Charles esten who
happens to be married in real life too
Charles's wife goes by the name Patti
Eston and the married couple have been
together for over 25 years they also
share three children together
Charles has expressed top-hat he makes
him happy and how he's lucky to have her
by his side he admits that he was naive
and immature as a young man when they
met and appreciates that she stuck by
him for all these years Charles and
Patti are an adorable couple here's to
another 25 years of marriage Rhoda is
one of the most eccentric mischievous
characters on the Jessie show she is a
resident of the Ross family's building
has a Chihuahua named Zeus and is on the
board of the building another odd
characteristic of Rhoda is her absurd
amount of ex-husbands
mr. Burge mr. Smith Victor mr. Holmes
Brooks Wentworth jr. and mr.
Chesterfield have all been married and
divorced to Rhoda the Brooks Wentworth
jr. is the father of Brooks Wentworth
but it's obviously easy to get them
confused
aside from Rhoda's ex-husbands she
doesn't have any other love interests on
the show Rhoda is played by Carolyn
Hennesy currently Carolyn is single but
she was married to
McNelly up until 2013 they were married
for six years in total
Carolyn hasn't appeared to be actively
dating but hopefully she finds love
again Agatha is another nanny of the
Ross family although she's known to be
much more wicked than Jessie even though
she was the mean nanny she deserved to
find love to her primary love interest
was officer Petey he is best known for
his obsession of improv and is often
boasting about his skills
unfortunately Agatha and officer Petey's
romance doesn't last very long officer
Petey is rather superficial and find out
that Agatha's mole and teeth are real
and he becomes scared of her
instead of romantically interested in
her Jennifer veal plays Agatha but
Jennifer is much more beautiful than
Agatha and real wife despite her
beautiful looks jennifer is currently
single although that's not to say that
her attractiveness means that she must
be dating someone she hasn't found love
yet but hopefully she's dating around
and looking for the one Stuart is the
character who is madly in love with Zuri
in the beginning Stuart strong feelings
for Zuri overwhelms her he frequently
sends her gifts asks her out and refers
to her by romantic nicknames in the end
xiri realizes she has feelings for
Stuart their relationship never works
out in the long run but Stuart always
remains a good friend Azzurri Stuart is
played by Josie tota Josie has
frequently played male roles in film but
she has recently made a transformation
into a transgender woman she's only 18
years old but claims that she has always
identified as female
despite her professional career her
friends and family have always known
this about her the only thing that's
changed recently is that she's been able
to present her identity publicly as
opposed to solely at home Josie is
currently single but she's still young
and discovering herself so it's
understandable that she hasn't settled
down yet Josie is a total inspiration
for people discovering their own
identity hopefully she finds someone who
loves her for who she is but there's no
rush she's got lots of time
that concludes the love lives of
characters on and off the screen of the
Jessie show for those that are in
relationships may it be full of love and
laughter for those that are single
hopefully you find what you're looking
for soon for more videos like this don't
forget to subscribe to the things